i'm neil gaiman author screenwriter
storyteller today i'm here to answer
your questions from twitter and this is
mythology support
[Music]
first one assaf mayor asks what links
viking
and greek
gods and myths
it's a lovely question because there are
things that are similar but what really
links them i think is people
the greeks
told their myths
to the romans and the romans took over
and colonized and then those same romans
traveled up and encountered
the
germanic tribes and the norse people and
traded tales of gods and heroes the
norse would talk
about odin the the romans would hear was
essentially mercury which is one reason
why our wednesday which is odin's day
right in the middle of the week is
mercury in france which is mercury's day
it's the same god crimson soul 21 says
if i asked nicely could i ride a
minotaur like a horse i'm english i say
minotaur americans say minotaur it's
weird to me could you ride a minotaur
like a horse no obviously you could not
you could ride a minotaur like a man
because you have a man body all the way
up to abel's head but that would mean
riding around on his shoulders
unless you could find a minotaur into
sort of you know
pony stuff or
you probably have to find a furry
minotaur like not a furry manager a
minotaur who was actually a furry would
get into a horse costume and get down
and you could ride that one this is
getting too weird i'm going to go on to
a different one
seth prime urbina and seth of course
is a good egyptian name asks if
egyptians worshipped cats
then why did anubis have a dog head
here is a picture
of anubis to clarify who we are talking
about technically he doesn't have a
dog's head i believe he has a jackal's
head i like this question this is this
is one of those questions if egyptians
worship cats then why did anubis have a
dog head is kind of like being asked you
know if if people descended from monkeys
why are they still monkeys
the answer is because the egyptians had
lots of gods
originally you had the gods of the upper
nile and the gods of the lower delta
and one set of gods were human and one
set of gods were animals and at the
point where egypt became all one country
the gods sort of incorporated each other
and you got a lot of animal-headed
humans from tiana marie underlying who
says after looking up what biblical
angels actually look like i fully
understand why they warn you not to be
afraid because wtf is that question mark
question mark question mark question
mark question mark question mark
question mark
you're right
what do biblical angels look like
they look like wings and eyes they look
like wheels they look like flying
saucers
which is kind of weird what they don't
look like rather disappointingly is
michael sheen and david tennant in good
omens i like the idea that they look
human-like because it would break our
brains
to see them as they really are mr darcy
asks why is every god in greek mythology
related to or king's use or both
king's use gets everywhere fucking's use
is all over the place which means that
an awful lot of people
are his descendants one way
or another the nice thing about gods is
nobody ever expected you to emulate them
they are always as much a warning as
they are aspirational you may want to
have godly powers
but you don't want to behave like that
you definitely don't want to behave like
zeus invert edit
asks
what is ragnarok essentially
ragnarok essentially is the last great
battle ragnarok essentially
begins with everything going wrong
the weather
goes wrong the climate goes wrong winter
does not end there is famine there is
awfulness
people are miserable brother fights
brother sister fight sister cousin
fights cousin there is a gigantic awful
civil war amongst the people and then it
gets worse
you get the frost giants coming out
they're led by certa a fire god
and loki
and his children and it is a monstrous
enormous
giant and pretty much final battle
that ends in everybody being dead i
haven't even mentioned that
all of the dead viking warriors get to
come back on an enormous
ship
built of the fingernails and toenails of
the dead because that's just too
weird
but they do and is why you should always
trim your nails however ragnarok kind of
has a happy ending
because after all of the awfulness
of ragnarok and after pretty much
everybody has died the few people who
don't die
get to sort of look at the ruins of
where
asgard was and everything gently starts
to grow again
and to begin again molly
asks why is all german folklore and
mythology absolutely terrifying what was
wrong with people i think it's something
to do with the food frankly it could be
the cold but it is absolutely true that
germanic folklore is terrifying it's
filled with adults eating children it's
filled with famine it's filled with
nightmare it's filled with
murder and awful things happening people
like horror stories sometimes because it
actually makes them feel better
next up
greenboy494 has a question in norse
mythology what are the most known gods
you know it is good that you're asking
me that question because i wrote
norse mythology by neil gaiman
and um as such i could tell you that
odin is probably the most important
frigg his wife also
well-known thor very well known gets
movies made
loki in the movies
loki is thor's brother
in the mythology loki is odin's
blood brother not actually related and
one of the
giants
but not
the big kind those are probably the most
known
gods
water dragon
asks
why is death so adorable in the sandman
death is so adorable in the sandman
because i wanted to create the kind of
death i would like to meet
when my life is over and i thought i
would like a death who is practical a
death who is sensible and a death who is
above all kind
the mythology of sandman is not world
mythology i should say that the
mythology of sandman is the mythology of
a comic that i
created which includes in it
seven entities who are not gods who are
not worshipped but are
essentially more powerful than gods
because gods die when they are forgotten
but the endless are always there and one
of those seven
is death vodam 46 says isn't loki
already gender fluid in norse mythology
uh yeah loki cheerfully
transforms into um
female form and is very happy doing so
uh loki becomes a mayor at one point
to while away
a uh a stallion who is just about to
finish bringing the stones to build a
wall for the gods
and
if the stallion cannot be stopped then
the gods are going to lose the sun
the moon and the beautiful freya loki is
told to stop them and loki
in a horse form in mere form
she lures that stallion away and then
turns up about a year later as loki with
an eight-legged foal a little horse
which is presented
to odin as odin's horse
gender fluid as hell absolutely
nathan k20 asks what is pandora's box
well first of all pandora's box isn't a
box
pandora's box is a jar zeus leads a war
against
the
titans who basically are zeus's parents
the gods win they have various people on
their side including a couple of titans
and their names are prometheus
and epimetheus
and epimetheus is given
a gift by the gods and the gift he is
given is pandora and everything's great
until one day
she out of curiosity or for whatever
reason
smashes a jar that she has in which all
of the things that are bad
all of the things that make life hard
the way that the story is sometimes told
that remains
after all of the evils in the world have
flown out into the world is hope
i've never been quite sure
how to interpret that because you can
think of hope as remaining as being this
wonderful pure
happy thing
or you can think of it as the final
cruelty of the gods
as they've lost they've loosed all of
these terrible things upon us and then
just to make it a little worse they've
given us all hope
asks why did icarus have to fly so close
to the sun bro
well it wasn't compulsory actually
his dad daedalus
explained to him that you don't fly
close to the sun they were escaping
together using wings
that daedalus had made and the wings
were held together
with wax
those of us
who
think that if you go up
it's going to get cold it would have
been proved wrong in ancient greek
mythology because they knew
that if you flew upwards you would get
too close to the sun and it would melt
the wax and if you went too far down
over the waves your wings would get wet
and what actually happened was the wings
melted
and icarus who aspired to go high
was drowned
sierra lachey asks
why thor missing an eye lol
thor not missing an eye your thinking of
odin being thor's dad
only has one eye odin is indeed missing
an eye because he traded an eye for
wisdom
tarot masks are says something that's
interesting to me is how so many
different cultures have great flood
myths
like why is that
probably because
over the years there have been an awful
lot of floods
and also
because
the great flood story
does
tend to get retold i think one of the
earliest versions we have of it
is the
the babylonian the assyrian version that
definitely predates noah during
the hundreds of thousands of years of
human history there were many times when
there were floods huge floods and lots
and lots of people died
and somebody didn't and the somebody who
didn't got to live and tell the story
next question is from celia the shaper
oh you're a greek mythology fan
name the 12 labors of hercules and then
there is a clown face
the 12 labors of hercules
are killed in a mean lion it is
important to remember that the namian
lion is not
the lions that provided the lion's skin
that hercules famously wore it was a
different line uh kill the the hydra the
linear hydra every time you cut off its
head it grows
two heads where the one that you cut off
was hercules actually got a buddy to
come in and cauterize the heads
as he cut them off capture the serenian
hind
that was a deer he's a hind the
aromantion bore you're starting to see
an animal pattern here and then you get
a
horsey one which isn't capture horses
it's clean the stables and this is the
aegean stables the filthiest stables in
the world and he did that rather
brilliantly i have to say by diverting a
river then you've got the stimphalian
birds these birds that would fly down
and
[ __ ] all over things and were awful and
murderous
killed them all
the cretan bull got them then uh we do
get horses again and this time it is
actually capturing them but these are
diameters is horses and they were
man-eaters you then have hippolyta's
belt
and uh or girdle and that one
does not end well he's done fairly well
dealing with animals but hippolyta is a
lady and in order to obtain her girdle
hercules has to
head off into the land of the amazons
they have a relationship it does not end
well definitely doesn't end well for
hippolyta who if memory serves kills
herself for love of hercules which is
really rather sad and he gets the belt
you've got the cattle of gary on and
that's the original 10 labors of
hercules and then he gets assigned
another two because he got help on two
of them he has to do the golden apples
of the hesperides
and finally
go to hell
and bring back cerberus kerberos the
three-headed dog of the underworld
t holzer man or falzer man asks greek
mythology question if two demigods bone
and they have a kid is that kid also a
demigod no that would be a hemi demigod
and obviously if their kids have sex
they will be semi hemi demigods and
beyond that you get into crotchets and
quavers and things well that's all the
questions i hope you learned something i
had a lot of fun thank you so much
here's to next time